salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
partie de pêche à la main on est en
compagnie du stagiaire est de retour et
surtout de fabrice les aimons cool d
humour geek avec aymeric on a fait les
petites trouvailles déjà regardé sac
regardez ce qu'ils ont des cartes vitale
tout sa carte d'identité on va montrer
la photo en coûtera le nom et le nom
machin carte bleue ces séries aussi
j'ai pas non je pense pas mais faut
regarder les dettes c'est peut être
intéressant d'avoir gardé on va dire
après bon il y avait deux chacun en fait
donc regarder la calculette en ma vie
c'était d'une entreprise
entreprise qu est ce qu il yad autres
parce qu'on a on a regardé mais vraiment
vite fait qu'aboyer stylo
trousseau de clés mais vraiment aidé
entre les nantis
des nombreuses clés
et là on est un petit spot là on a déjà
fait un coffre fort j'aimerais que la
sortie une part quand vous mettra la
voulais filmer mais dès que vous postez
nous on la mettra en descriptions donc
peut-être que la vidéo sortira avant
mais on leur rajoutera pas propre et
donc c'est un spot avec un petit
ruisseau
donc voila tout petit mais mais qui
réservent pas mal de 200 petits tubes
dette avant d'attaquer la pêche à
leyment fabrice a réussi à retrouver la
propriétaire de ce sac à main qui a été
victime d'une agression assez violente
il ya quelques mois durant laquelle on
lui a dérobé son sac et une importante
somme d'argent donc voilà il a réussi à
la retrouver pour lui restituer les
papiers qu'elle n'avait pas encore
refait pour certains et ce qui pouvait
l'intéresser qui étaient encore présents
dans le sac rohmer 3 de la journée pour
le stagiaire pour le bareback demain est
ce que c'est un vrai la gueule non
9 en tout cas ouais bien joué ouais
belle dépollution ça envoie par derrière
par derrière et tu ramènes vers la
fin j'ai encore à tout - c'est pas ça
c'est à dire c'est plus que ça bien des
choses
ont pu rester jour où on a besoin de toi
antoine
non pas sûr non
il n'aurait rien trône avec ton est
monté
[Musique]
à c'est un beau bébé way
apparaissait de quoi certainement de
dans la whey
ça je vais lâcher
pour me reprendre
le combinat morceau quoi il est
tellement violent orage des morceaux de
corps
[Musique]
séparé stopper
premier cardozo [ __ ]
comment les manois en laiton elle est
magnifique alors
incroyable et mickey
c'est collector ouais bon vouloir des
petits trautmann est
sympa il montre aux avants dommage mes
trouvailles cool et là c'était déjà
poisson en bon état une menace
ouais allez
les abrutis
les gars
[Musique]
j'essaie dé s'en va-t-en on va essayer
de le faire basculer la main
ok c'est bon on est passé dessus de juin
les gars
jouent les coffres bravo à tous il est
d'époque bravo à tous voir la première
fois qu'on france en baroeul pour
bien jouer rasta et là du coup y'a pas
un arrière fond quoi et une plaque
du coup les moules d'autre part un lot
de dent
may well halak est vraiment belle c'est
une roue c'est une routine euros
avec à ramener là bas sera placée pour
le second
l'at on a peur
hélas hélas
pour avoir
regardé ce que j'ai sorti le classique
ça y'en a partout
au un couteau
couteau rond n'ont pas rond
[Musique]
waouh
bouteilles de gaz ou je sais pas quoi la
boule de pétanque et boules de pétanque
là je vais là coincée comme ça
regardez c'est en tonnes
pour cette
attaque au couteau ouais
il y en a plein ici un cf le nombre de
couteau qu'on a fait
l'état ouais j'ai fait le même à peu
près l ag quelque chose
c'est un sac non
ouais un très vieux cinq
fois et la fois ci du ve plastique
alors s'il reste des choses dedans
barrières rien
ainsi mais un pendentif
quoi chez ram et ouais enfin dirait un
vieux pendentif fois ici un truc qui
peut être un coffre
mais c'est dans la vase alors antoine
cdh
et restent à quai sans pense
a les bonnes choses
mais là c'est bien là un truc qui vient
là
[Musique]
vous
howe bennoo
à
[Musique]
génial regarder
ça c'est la classe les gars super alors
hop pension ou à la vase la quantité de
vase et des papiers il ya des paquets
c'est bon
ça c'est du cuir on voit que c'est de la
qualité
regardez ça
non c'est un art où tu mets les pieds
carrés c'est un grand joueur à pied
c'est vrai rat dommage les pièces de
collection ça aurait été cool d'être hop
on n'aurait peut-être pas encore
ceinture un
moyen qui me semble ça s'annonce assez
terne attache une valise garçons qui
veulent y êtes elle a totalement fondu
là j'ai quelque chose de rigide
intérieur
il ya des choses entre c'était des
pochettes de pièces en commun la non
c'est bizarre ça devait être une
collection de pièces
on regarde ses 10 ans c'est un portable
oui trop bien
[Musique]
le portable des voleurs ça regarde donc
c'est une batterie ils ont viré le
quartier bela la batterie au marché un
système 3003
à regarder des inscriptions la
grâce à un coup il ya écrit des trucs là
dessus c'est un jeu
il écrit pièces en euros 2 euros je suis
génial restauration au
combat ils ont pas laissé de pièces en
louisiane a vu là un batîment c'est
byzance il faut c'est un centime kwh de
temps à les gars je crois que j'ai les
cartes à
expire en 2014
j'étais pas loin ouais
c'est 14 de
regarder
les belles petites perles et on l'a
génial
super on a eu tort ouais
ouais donc neutre quelque chose dans le
rinçage elle est comme aimantés au
coffre sort pas à est d'accord à
décoller sa carte bleue pire en 2012
celle là donc c'était en 2012 ou quoi
oui avant 2012 alors ouais c'est vieux
c'est vieux
sympa
ça vient oh les gars venez nous aider
des cannes
des canards et l'eau et c'est en vélo
hinault par lots comme ça c'est la vase
bien joué mais il est bien bmx
la miss sauver les enfants
regardent la taille des roues avant par
rapport à la voir hier tu vois ce qui
est dommage c'est que l'on a ici elle
est un peu salée soit beau mec mais
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire regarde la
différence de taille des roues
je fais un peu sale non ça va as tu
montes pas d'un voiture comme ça
je te mettrai en caleçon pour aller
acheter des courses on va aller acheter
à manger tu veux être comme ça ça va
bien
on verra le stagiaire il est encore
propres
on va se baigner dans la mer d'abord moi
se garer à la mer
arrête pas les roquentins
pas les roues bon j'arrête de fumer vous
êtes trop long
les le faire c'est des humains
il te prêter d'anguilles antoine
un bien dit que tu étais une envie
encore s'accroît à temps
ouais
eh oui
gas on a tout à coup
non mais on a perdu a démenti et non
maîtrise il a raison faut l'attraper
mais on s'en fout ce
gouvernement non
alors elle boxing
dormi chez nos riches entre
deux coffres
des plombs
gévelot
tv web c'est
super c'est des plans ou salut 6 mm
bosquet d'accord mais c'est trop cool
ancêtres une carabine la hotte était
alors en mission au canada c'était la
balle c'est trop beau en général ça
ouais c'est déçoivent petit pistolet
carabine
parce que ce serait pas un temps
important
webroot vélo
n'est pas jeune
je vois qu'on fait les gants de quoi ce
soir aux gyrophares
ouais ouais
gyrophare de police via le câble via le
câble non aux purs et imaginaire mais
c'est trop bien
j'adore ça c'est cool
clairement j'ai le même temps avec rob
d'office comment ces éléments il marche
encore
pourquoi on irait en intervention de
pêche à des membres vip au vieux
on s'accroche bien
voilà en place ce soir l'équipe de 50
minutes inside accompagne la brigade
d'intervention des pêcheurs aliments ce
ne sont peut-être pas les coups tordus
plus affûtée du tutorat mais puisque
c'est une brigade spéciale aie fait de
la merde là quelques secondes plus tard
le giro pour nous a lâché n'hésitez pas
à déposer votre pouce bleus sous cette
vidéo pour soutenir ce pauvre
[Musique]
pour cette chaise ou quoi
super un poste cassette salon ah ouais
bon comme il à l'envi eux regardent pas
les fréquences il est cool bien
conservés vintage et on le met dans
l'opel vectra suis là ou pas a les
moyens légaux pour moi j'ai quelque
chose à
c'est quoi ça un cadre
où il ya une piètre avec jets des
pierres sur les mains
concentre aussi
super bon ben
c'est quoi comme pièce
pierre
nuls c'est bizarre ces choses ok ok
comme dirait nab s'emparerait
j'avais une déclaration on a toujours
quoi manger donc si balances ton stage
passe par ici j'aimerais qu'il y ait une
petite intervention sur ce stage car ça
va pas du tout
extincteur ou grenade
15h05 bis ouais ouais t'as raison
antoine ces extincteurs je suis déçu
dix ans de plus
c'est vrai
la ferraille
c'est peut-être ça rit un truc là qui
j'aimerais
juste là
là au fond au milieu là
ouais
ces pêcheurs de plusieurs
bords le couteau et jolie
pas l'arrêt stop sauna inox
non
les fusées une fois dedans a péché une à
la marché mais il rappelle que nous ont
dit que c'était super dangereux donc on
va plus refaire
c'est quoi qui l'ont acheté des
médicaments
nolad
wa
belle trouvaille des aimants cool
non dégoupillées fonctionnel
dans la bleue dans grenade à plâtre
bois tout il ya quand même une petite
charge soit dans le détonateur mais
juste assez pour la faire exploser quoi
parents travers toutes dévissé tout
bizarre c'est pas normal que ça bouge
comme ça une fois il ya un mec qu'on a
croisés qui pêchait un élément qui nous
a dit que les vapes les gendarmes et lui
avait dit quelques couleurs à l'est la
grenade et il avait dit bleu et du coup
ils ont dit des goûts pilat et jette là
mais bon je pense qu'on va peut-être
passer risque est là ça fait quand même
peur
meiway très belles trouvailles sympa
mais mon cool super
bon c'est toujours impressionnant de
voir la grenade avec la forme
si asahi noir n'importe quoi ici du coup
la mauvaise nouvelle ouais serono gros
travail de ces verrous alors là surtout
sortir et sous le treuil sous le carton
c'est peut-être énervé mais je suis pas
sûr alors faites dans le sud non c'est
chaud au cul de vue mais là ils rendent
de l'ofag à se planter au moins trente
30 40 cm quelle couleur gris couleur
chrome et
ses couleurs chrome et occupent tout
gris
[Applaudissements]
il protège pas
[Musique]
il faudrait à tout pour essayer de le
bloquer ou quoi un bâton ou quoi ouais
ou
dans le carton
ah oui
c'est vrai buteur
[Musique]
kg alors 3 qui viendra
donc
non mais vous êtes sérieux là
inquiète elle est là là
là bien cool de dans l'ue
ouais c'est bon là cela va pas
l'habitude
allez
hockey probable sauvetage réussie
mais les baleines
on va voilà la vidéo de pécharmant tous
à sa faim donc du très très lourd ou
encore une fois ce coin bravo vraiment
cool pour le spot ouais super gros
coffre deux petits ici bonjour à plaisir
avec un pêcheur trésor c'est que ça va
ramener du lourd aller à la prochaine
ère bush n oubliez pas de vous abonner